so thank you all for coming out to this
and hopefully we'll have an interesting
discussion over the kinds of work and in
particular this project which really
seeks to blend very specifically
humanities disciplinary ways of knowing
and understanding text with a wider
approach that takes advantage of the
kind of computation that we can do and
and as Michael said I run an
organization called the literary lab
over in English and that's really what
we understand our mandate to be which is
we are focused particularly on
understanding text mostly literary text
although we tend to venture outside one
of the nice things about doing this kind
of quantitative work is that I can
travel a bit outside of my home fields
we have collaborative projects with the
law school with political science with
anthropology who are all interested in
understanding the ways that texts work
historically and how they work formally
how do people understand things from the
act of reading and this project I wanted
to share with you because we're
particularly excited about it it's
fairly new I'm warning you right now
it's not entirely baked but in some ways
that makes it more interesting to share
and talk about because this is still
very much research in progress and
before I leap into it I also want to say
that I do run it works a little bit
differently than a science lab but it's
still a lab like environment and so when
I present I'm used to interacting with
with people so if at any point you've
got questions you want clarification etc
etc feel free to ask me anything as we
go along I'm happy to to chat and make
this as informal as as you'd like so
this is a project called micro genres
and before I really describe what we're
trying to do I want to acknowledge that
I'm going to say we throughout the talk
and by we I really do mean we this is
actually the team from the lab that has
been working on this for about eight
months or so and and we're a group that
combines
faculty graduate students undergraduates
and some people from outside who all
come at this project from different
angles and and that's actually really
important to the kind of work that we do
particularly in a project like this that
has so many different angles that is
we're all interested in learning
different things and and in different
methods of learning things from the
project
so micro genres and and we're still
debating the name I'm very much in fond
of micros honours because it's a great
sounding name but it's a little opaque
we're interested in knowing how
disciplinary style functions at the
level of the novel in other words when a
novel stops being a novel and becomes
something else for a little while is
that something that we as human readers
can pick up on and interpret ourselves
or are their formal characteristics that
let us see when that happens and more
importantly how that happens so for
example here is an example of what we're
calling a micro Genoa from Isaac
Asimov's foundation novel classic sci-fi
and and there's a really very startling
break there there's there's an excerpt
from something called the Encyclopedia
Galactica which tries to sound like an
encyclopedia and then a movement into
narrative so we get sort of the history
of terminus the planet followed by Lewis
pure n was busily engaged in his desk in
the one well-lit there's there's a very
clear style there here very obviously
signaled by by a movement from an
encyclopedia or you know a fake
encyclopedia a narrative encyclopedia
fictional encyclopedia to what we might
consider to be narrative this is a
really obvious example of the kind of
thing we're interested in unfortunately
it's usually not that apparent take for
example Octavia Butler's novel the
parable of the talents this is narrative
but it's narrative that's describing the
history of the disease that the novel
takes as its subject so it's a care
Derr in first person talking to the
audience as characters in first person
novels tend to do but not in a style
that's typical to the novel instead here
we have a character telling history and
the question that we're trying to ask is
when a character is doing this are they
still talking or are they communicating
in the style of the novel or is there a
kind of style switch where this might
look more like history than it does a
novel if you really want to get
next-level about it here's William
Godwin's Caleb Williams from 1794 I'm
showing you these three examples because
they're getting sort of increasingly
difficult in terms of their
identification so in the first one we
had that very clear kind of haptic break
we can see that this is an encyclopedia
entry followed by narrative the second
example from Butler looks like narrative
but reads like history this is this is
something else this is Caleb Williams
it's at Keller Williams for those of you
who don't know it and I'm not expecting
you necessarily do it's a gothic novel
kind of from the late eighteenth century
in which an evil squire is is pursuing
this poor Caleb Williams who's
discovered a terrible secret about him
across across the land of England and
and in this scene he's been Caleb
Williams has been put in jail by the
evil squire and reflects upon the nature
of the of the human mind when it is
imprisoned and the reason I show this is
a good example is because God went
actually wrote two books at the same
time he wrote a book called political
justice which was an early political
book about how to reform the laws of
England to to make them better but he
also wrote this novel Caleb Williams
which was supposed to be an example of
how those recommendations in political
justice can be put into practice and so
here there's an interesting movement
between sort of a description of a
character in a particular situation but
at the same time trying to
philosophically enact these ideas about
political justice and what it
means four characters or four people who
are politically imprisoned and so
Godwin's doing something really
deliberate here that is he's trying to
use a novel to convince his audience
about his political ideas and and the
question again becomes when he does this
does this look more like a novel or does
this look more like God when inserting a
bit of political theory into what should
otherwise be a fairly straightforward
gothic narrative these are the kinds of
moments that we want to find and we want
to find them for a couple of reasons so
these are the questions that have
animated the project where we're looking
for shifts between disciplinary styles
within what should be fictional writing
so do micro genres exist at the level of
style and can we detect them
computationally what are the features
that signal to the reader that you've
moved out of narrative and into history
or science or anthropology or psychology
do those features exist in style or are
they merely lexical features when do
these kinds of narrative shifts occur do
they is there any kind of pattern in
terms of when they happen in novels or
do particular genres show different
kinds of patterns that is do historical
novels or science fiction novels handle
these kinds of shifts between narrative
and other kinds of writing differently
in my own field of literary studies the
so called heteroglossia of the novel is
is something that's that's fairly well
understood that is we understand novels
to be assembled jiz of different kinds
of writing that are all stuck together
to create what seems to the reader to be
a seamless narrative experience but
actually can be decomposed into these
different according to Bakhtin
democratic voices so the kind of thing
we're interested in has antecedents
within the discipline of literary
studies within the humanities but
usually when people study Bakhtin's
heteroglossia what they do is they read
a novel and say well I think this part
is one kind of voice and this parts a
different kind of voice and therefore
Bakhtin was right QED the end we wanted
to do something a little bit more
computational we wanted to do something
that lets us really dig into and say
does this happen and if it does happen
how does it happen so we had to
establish a corpus and I'll show you a
couple of slightly different ones but
the main one that we used is from a 1870
to 1914 and we chose this because this
is a really important moment when what
we now consider to be disciplines like
literary studies like anthropology
psychology natural science etc etc
really came into being in both the US
and the UK these are just some facts
about the periods that we chose but you
can see that in addition to things like
the second land-grant Act in 1890 and
the rise of civic universities in in the
1900 just the number of degrees awarded
if we understand degrees as a sign of
disciplinarity within the institution of
the university that is you can get a PhD
or a BA in anthropology or you can get
an MS in physics you can really see that
in this period there's a there's a
massive increase in the number of
degrees that are being awarded so this
seemed if we were gonna find something
like a period to actually go look at
when we might be able to see the
interaction between these early
disciplines and the ways in which novels
were being written for the feature set
we talked a lot about this and it turned
out that this was a really interesting
choice because we didn't want to use
lexemes a lot of what we do over in
cultural analytics or computational
literary studies we look at words we
count words and that's that's very
productive is in fact you'll see in a
little bit but here we wanted to do
something different because the argument
we were trying to make is that when this
happens it doesn't depend on the words
that are being used that is if I'm
writing along in a novel and all of a
sudden I switch from writing a novel to
writing anthropology for a few paragraph
the words that I use to do that might
not be the same as what anthropologists
are using to write about anthropology
that is in early ethnography studies we
might they find words like tribe or like
people's or like artifacts and I might
as a novelist use different kinds of
words but the question that we had is
when people make these kinds of switches
do they write in the style of the
discipline so what we decided to do was
adopt a set of features that are more
indicative of kinds of writing rather
than the subject so what we decided to
extract from all of our texts in our
corpus are the percentage of all of the
part of speech based predominant
predominantly on the penn treebank the
number of verbs past present whatever
tense the number of gerron's the number
of proper nouns singular nouns pronouns
et cetera et cetera
the number of people who are named the
number of places that are named the
average length of sentences and the
number of clauses per sentence that
gives us some kinds of complexity
measurements as well so this is the
feature set that we decided to use and
we decided to take a modeling approach
and we decided on a linear
classification or a linear discriminant
analysis sorry for many reasons but but
there were two chief advantages one it's
really easy to decompose the model as
opposed to something like a deep
learning neural net and two it gives us
percentage probabilities of class
membership because what we're really
interested in is not places where the
model worked but places where the model
didn't work in other words if we can
teach a computer to tell the difference
between anthropology writing psychology
writing economics writing history
writing a novel writing then the places
in a novel where the computer says I
don't think this is a novel I think this
is history that's the place where we're
hoping we're gonna find these kinds of
disciplinary style shifts so we
separated the corpus which I'll explain
to you in a second or I'll show you what
that is into a training in a test set we
we had different
numbers of things in each discipline in
novels so we had to do some down
sampling and then we classified
everything to create a model or we
classify the training sets ready to
create a model we test it on the test
set and then we could go to the novels
and use that model in order to see what
parts of the novels look like novels and
what part look like something else yeah
please and you create a statement how do
you know so as you'll see I'll show you
examples we tried a number of different
sized segments we wanted to separate at
the sentence level because that gave us
complete syntactically units which makes
the protis peach easier tagging but we
tried it in two hundred sentence
segments 100 sentence a quince 52 and 20
because we weren't sure how how the
different segment size wouldn't interact
between these kinds of shifts and it
turns out we find different things at
different segment sizes which turned out
to be super interesting and something we
weren't expecting so what we did is we
took ten books from seven academic
disciplines that existed during this
period between 1870 and 1914 10
anthropology books economics books
history and and this is not obviously a
comprehensive list of disciplines that
existed one of the favorite games of
every one that I present this to is to
say what about what about journalism
what about sermons what about theology
what about and it's true all of that is
true you're absolutely right we would
have been much more comprehensive but
but these we felt were disciplines that
a we were interested in seeing how they
were inserted in the novel and B they
also had monographs from this period
that we could use to compare against the
novels but but I'm very open to see
other suggestions of other things that
you think would be interesting for us to
look at because we can easily add other
other disciplines to the model which
have to find the texts
this there's very little computer
science funny enough written in 1870
there's this Charles Babbage and I think
that's about it for a period yeah um so
to compare against we just selected 26
novels we selected these novels not
randomly they're all canonical they're
not all originally or at sorry they're
all originally written in English but
not always by native speakers of English
we thought that would be interesting and
as an initial test we thought that they
would all potentially have possibly
interesting micro generic moments and
they just they were just an easy corpus
of novels to get and they were fairly
clean so we created a model and it turns
out that at 200 sentence segments that
is when we divide all of the text into
200 sentence segments build a model and
then test it we can classify
disciplinary style correctly around 78%
of the time which is kind of astonishing
because we're not using lexical features
this is just grammatical features with
just parts of speech and sentence
complexity question one are other things
as just such as disciplinary styles it
turns out yeah they're kind of our
different disciplines even this early on
right differently and that was an
important first discovery it's
interesting that some of them are very
clear and some of them are less clear
for example natural science is mostly
classified correctly as natural science
it turns out natural scientists write
fairly distinctly anthropology and
psychology at the end less distinct
slightly more difficulty classifying
them when you move from 200 sent in
segments down to 50 our our
classification percentage drops a bit
down to 66 although if we're comparing
against chance this is still pretty good
because chance would be around 12% if
this was just randomly assigned so we're
still we're still well above chance some
things have gotten slightly worse like
natural science but still predominantly
some things I can't
apology the majority of our anthropology
50 sentence segments still classified is
but there were more likely to classify
as anthropology than anything else but
there clearly was a less anthropological
style then say for example a historical
style and and this will be important now
when we got to the thing we really
wanted to know that is the novels
themselves what we could do is take the
200 sentence segments of the novel and
use our classifier to guess what each
one was this is just a Conrad's novel
Nostromo each bar is a 200 sentence
segment of the novel from beginning to
end so there are roughly 20 1 2 3 4 5 6
200 sentence segments in Nostromo and
the bar color represents the
distribution of probability of cluster
of group membership so for example the
teal bars are is the percentage
likelihood that it's a novel and it
turns out most of the novel Nostromo was
guessed as being a novel which is good
because if it wasn't then we might have
a problem but that bar right there
number 11 is not classified as a novel
in fact it's some mixture of history and
anthropology so this was actually pretty
cool because this lets us dig into those
particular places where the computer
says wait this doesn't look like a novel
and see if in fact this was or was not a
novel are there in fact shifts that
might be disciplinary in nature now it
turns out that most of our novels look
like that which again is good I guess
because it means that novels are being
understood as novels but not so much
interesting for our projects this is a
portrait of a lady and Sons and Lovers I
gave a version of this talk in Paris
about six months ago it was really funny
because the first question I got from
the French literary studies audiences
wait can you use this to guess the most
pure novel
it's the question I should have expected
and yes yes you can and in fact it turns
out Sons and Lovers is is purely a novel
which is actually kind of true but this
is not the most interesting kind of
result in fact many of our novels did
show really interesting points were they
departed from what we might consider the
style of the novel into what turned out
to be really interesting disciplinary
insertions so for example this is the
very first Sherlock Holmes story written
by Sir Arthur Conan Doyle it's called a
Study in Scarlet and as you can see by
the graph this is 200 centons segments
most of it again was classified as a
novel with one really big exception and
I didn't bother marking it out on the
PowerPoint because I assumed you could
all see the one exception that we have
that is sentence or segment number eight
does not look at all like a novel but
instead is evenly split between
anthropology and Natural Science so we
decided to take a closer look at a
segment eight and this is what we found
the novel is actually I don't know if
any of you have encountered it but the
novel is actually really interesting in
that it's really cleanly divided in half
the first half of the novel is a typical
Sherlock Holmes and Watson story where
Sherlock Holmes and Watson are on the
trail of these series of grisly murders
that take place in London and eventually
through clever and subtle machinations
and good detective work they catch the
person and that turns out to be fine but
then it turns out that the reason that
the person was wandering around London
killing these specific people is because
said said criminal had had this past in
the United States and so midway through
the novel the action switches from
contemporary London to a story about the
Mormons in Utah Territory and that bar
which looked like something besides a
novel this is this is a segment of text
from it
is exactly where the story shifts and
the story shifts first by describing the
natural scenery of Utah the barrenness
the the the rivers that flow through
these are Swift flowing rivers which
dash through jagged canyons they're
enormous plains where which-which and
winter are white with snow etc etc then
later in that 200 centons segment we
move from a description of the natural
scenery to a description of the Mormons
the Mormons that show up with their
wagon train and the ways in which they
interact being remarked upon by both the
character and the narrator this is a
segment that's classified half as
Natural Science and half as anthropology
the first half of the passage is this
description of the natural scenery of
Utah the second half a description of
the Mormon people natural science
anthropology it seemed it does seem that
in fact what we have discovered is a
kind of correct classification that this
is a part of the novel that split fairly
evenly between these two disciplinary
modes when we move down to 50 sentence
segments and again this is exactly like
the the graph before except instead of
200 sentences they're each each bar
represents 50 sentences the parting
question happens right here so it's no
longer a single bar instead it is three
the first one predominantly classified
as Natural Science the second one almost
entirely novel and the third
predominantly anthropology and when we
actually dig down into what these 350
sentence segments are we find that the
first one is in fact that description of
the natural scenery of Colorado or of
Utah in Colorado that in fact this is
doyle trying his very best to give an
accurate description of the landscape
much like a natural scientist of the
late 19th century would that second bar
which was classified almost
predominantly as a novel after the
natural history description we moved to
a dialogue between the primary character
and
his young Ward this was classified
almost entirely as a novel which I kind
of agree with and then that third bar we
move to the actual description of the
Mormons themselves anthropology natural
science novel anthropology this is
actually kind of astonishing and this is
in the lab something we have to keep
reminding ourselves because it turns out
that yeah micro genres exist and they
kind of work but but they work in a way
that's really difficult to explain to
ourselves because this is the natural
science passage and when I read it I
will say yeah this is natural science
because he's talking about rivers he's
talking about valleys he's talking about
geographic features that makes perfect
sense except none of those things are
what the computer sees right we see this
the reader sees this this is what the
computer sees this is what the
classification is based on and one of
the most difficult parts of the project
so far has been to try and figure out
how this translates into an experience
of anthropology or psychology or of
natural natural science or history in
other words there seem to be clear
grammatical features that signal these
disciplinary shifts that we recognize
from the lexemes but really are
operating at levels below the lexical so
we tried a number of different ways
here's an unsuccessful one we actually
went through and colored all of the
passages in all of the novels for the
different parts of speech in the hopes
that we could recognize well this
clearly has a lot of nouns and this one
has a lot of adjectives or adverbs and
it turns out that's not a good way to do
it because it's really hard to read
slightly better is that we correlated
the classification probability with the
different features that is things that
are more likely to be classified as
Natural Science have more clauses per
sentence and longer sentences and a lot
of determiners so those and us whereas
things that are classified as
comics tend to have a lot of proper
nouns a lot of adjectives and again a
high mean sentence length whereas novels
tended to be personal pronouns and a lot
of named people which which kind of
makes sense so this gave us a way to
begin to understand how the computer was
making decisions that would hopefully
enable us to unpack why different
disciplinary styles were working the way
that they were now we had a couple of
questions we had a couple of possible
confounding effects that we wanted to
dig a little bit into for example
authorship any of you who are familiar
with text analysis know that author
signals are really really really strong
that is if you just look at the most
frequent words and you do some kind of
classification based on that the first
thing you will always find is authorship
and we were worried that the computer
was using author signals as a way to
disambiguate different kinds of writing
so we wanted to dig into that a little
bit so what we used was a perfect test
case of someone who is published in two
different disciplines
Isaac Asimov who I started with very
prolific science fiction writer but also
a super prolific textbook writer in
science so we made a corpus of a science
fiction novel 17 of them as well as an
equal number of words of science text
which includes popular science books as
well as some articles that he wrote when
we we picked from the same span of time
from 1950 to 1993 and we wanted to see
if we could replicate the same
experiment in miniature that is in just
Asimov just looking at the discipline of
science writing and novel writing are
there places where we could detect when
Asimov stops writing a novel and starts
writing more like his science stuff and
again yeah we can we this is our 50
sentence segment and and again we
classified fairly accurately 95% of the
time we could tell whether or not 50
sentence segments was novel in read or
science in blue and when we actually go
to his novels we find again
mostly science but or sorry mostly novel
but really important points where it
seems to move from a novel style into a
science style here obviously these two
and again digging in that first one is
is a character named Arkady writing an
essay for her class on the history of
the foundation so azimoff is able to in
the middle of his narrative stop writing
a narrative and move into science
writing that second one is actually
another segment from the Encyclopedia
Galactica
which again Asimov uses in order to
introduce certain kinds of history into
his narrative that he then doesn't need
to have his characters explained so
again even in just azimoff's corpus
controlling for both date and author
affects the process that we've devised
is able to use these grammatical signals
to find these micro generic shifts here
the features are slightly different it
turns out that mean sentence length is
really important
Asimov science math science essays have
really long sentences as it turns out
but but the percentage of determiners
and adjectives and cardinal digits is
also really important as well in the
same way if we went down to 20 sentence
slices our classification drops a little
bit down to 91 percent but still pretty
good and we find slightly different
segments that that at the smaller
sentence scale inactive this kind of
micro generic shift in in miniature so
for example number 46 is this section
from second foundation in which the the
two main characters land on a planet and
they're immediately quizzed about their
equipment and their material in their
way of life by the primitive so-called
primitive residents on the planet the
second one is is an explanation of how a
kind of brain in cephalad rafi works
within the world of the foundation so
again in both cases we seem to be able
to detect these kinds of disciplinary
shifts
through these not really
misclassifications
but classic Ettore procedure and again
it turns out that means sentence
lengthen in azimoff is really important
as our as our determiners but equally
the the use of comparative adjectives
for example in in novels so we felt that
we'd satisfied ourself that in fact
there aren't confounding author effects
and what we were finding is is actually
something real and stylistic but then we
started wondering about semantics how
does our ability to compare different
shifts grammatically compare with our
ability to detect these kinds of shifts
semantically that is is there a
difference between how authors
transition from writing about novels
into writing history art form writing a
novel into writing history is there a
difference between that how that happens
at the style level and how that happens
at the level of individual words
so we'd established a semantic set of
features the 200 most frequent word
nouns the 75 most frequent verbs and the
25 each of adjectives and adverbs and
reran the experiment using this as a
feature set as it turns out somewhat
unsurprisingly it turns the words are
really good at classifying different
kinds of writing as we expected there to
be across our seven orig or eight sorry
original different kinds of writing we
were 90% accurate in guessing what each
segment came from what's really
interesting about this is that these
started showing us different segments of
the novel then our grammatical feature
set so for example back to study in
scarlet that segment that was clearly
anthropology in Natural History which is
29 30 and 31 reads lexically as a novel
but there are these other places that
turns out even though grammatically
they're like a novel lexically they're
not so take for example section 20 which
is classified using semantic features
the actual words as history and when we
look at that
what we actually find is Watson
recounting what the newspapers were
saying about the attempts to solve the
mystery
so using lexical features we can find
different segments that seem to be doing
the same kinds of shifts but doing them
differently when we actually looked at
the the correlations again this is this
is one of my favorite graphs because
it's it really puts a finger on what
each of these disciplines thinks it's
about so if you look at philosophy the
novels that the words that most highly
correlated with something being
philosophy were reality Beauty sense
object relation Natural Science with
species plants and animals economics
production labor capital I particularly
love psychology with dream element
movement and consciousness so again a
completely different way of
understanding how these different
transitions happen and the ways in which
they try they happen differently
depending on whether or not the author
is adopting the style of a different
discipline or the language of a
different discipline so putting it all
together we decided to graph everything
at once with the single most complicated
graph I think has ever come out of my
lab it's actually really useful as a
heuristic tool not so pretty to look at
it's actually referred to colloquially
among the lab is the Krakken so behold
the Krakken here each dot is a segment
of the text at the 50 sentence scale so
each dot is a 50 sentence chunk of text
the color is what discipline it should
come it actually did come from so all of
the yellow dots for example really are
sections of natural science books the
shape whether it's a square or a circle
is whether or not it was classified as
grammatical or lexical and the size is
the inverse of how well it was
classified so backing up just a second
because I realized I should have led
with this and didn't say it the position
of each dot on the graph is a dimension
reduction of its probabilities of
membership in each of our discipline
so we used the probability of membership
as a feature set so things that are a
hundred percent classified as novels
show up next to other novels things that
are 100 percent classified as natural
science show up next next to natural
science and things that are half
classified as natural science half as a
novel should should show up next to each
other and so the size shows how good the
class or how correct the classification
is the bigger the more unlike what they
actually are they showed up the smaller
the more like what they were actually
are showed up and what you can see
immediately from this when you separate
at the lexical and the grammatical is
that there's a really big difference in
classification so taking out all of the
lexical features or all the lexical
classifications the center is occupied
predominantly by things that are
classified grammatically but not
correctly classified grammatically so
the center seems to be the space of miss
classification looking just at our
lexical classifications you can see that
we have a movement out towards the edge
where things are classified much more
correctly things are what they say they
are so we can use this to actually look
at the neighborhoods of each of the
segments that we're interested in
reading so for example this is this is
the same graph except I've removed
everything but the disciplines that
aren't novels and Sherlock Holmes a
Study in Scarlet so the only novel on
this graph is is a Study in Scarlet so
you can take a look at this little
section of madness right there and if we
zoom in you can see Sir Arthur Conan
Doyle a Study in Scarlet number 29 which
is that big blue dot sitting next to
those two small yellow squares which are
natural science this is this is the
segment describing the natural scenery
of Utah which you can see clearly
occupies a place closest to certain
kinds of Natural Science in the same way
zooming in on this part you can see
Arthur Conan Doyle listed in Scarlet 31
which looks most like anthropology but
in an interestingly confused way because
there's also some economics and
natural science next to it as well if
you look at the lexical features this is
that part that was classified lexically
as history it is the most obvious in
that it is that blue square surrounded
by all those little green dots so it is
most clearly a movement lexically into
history
so micro zones exist we can detect them
what can we do with that well a very
blunt level we can spend some time
simply reading them take for example
these two graphs which are on the top
the Picture of Dorian Gray by Oscar
Wilde classified grammatically and at
the bottom using our lexical features
this lets us not only find places in
this rather interesting novel that are
not apparently novel it also lets us
look at how they are differently not
novel depending on whether or not we're
looking at style or we're looking at the
words take for example this piece which
actually is interesting because it's one
of the few that is both misclassified in
the same way by style and by lexical and
both number I'm looking particularly at
number 74 in both grammatical style and
in both lexemes it's classified
predominantly as history on our giant
graph you can find it right there again
I've only marked the two passages again
in this area of very strong historical
writing when we actually look at the
text what we find is that this is when
Dorian Gray gets really into the study
of gems like super into the study of
gems to the point where he spends an
entire page of the book giving the
history of various kinds of gems
so both grammatically and lexically this
is identified a place where there is a
really strong movement towards history
this is clearly Wilde stopping the novel
and moving into history for a brief
period of time and just to remind you of
what those features are that let us find
that in terms of the grammatical
features a lot of places
a lot of people and a lot of clauses and
in lexically a lot of passed tends to be
a lot of England a lot of King a lot of
years things that make sense when you
actually look at them together but are
actually really hard for a reader to
pick up more interesting this is from
Bram Stoker's Dracula are these places
in the novel like here where both
lexically and grammatically the model
identifies them as something that's not
a novel but there's a disagreement as to
what it is here this post to be a
section that's Natural Science according
to its style but history according to
its lexemes according to the actual
words in the passage again zooming in on
the graph you can see that that the two
sections exist again in the same space
but in slightly different places next to
both next to both Natural Science as
well as next to history depending on
whether or not you're looking at it
lexically or grammatically Dracula is
interesting because there are these very
deliberate shifts on the part of Stoker
into what he's trying to convince the
reader are different styles of writing
so this particular segment is actually a
place where Stoker is writing as if he
were a newspaper reporter reporting on
the fate of the ship that brings Dracula
to England the ghost ship the Demeter
that shows up in port with all of the
crew mysteriously dead and the newspaper
reporter goes on board and writes this
story about it it's a really interesting
moment because Stoker is explicitly
signaling that he's not writing a novel
he's trying to mimic the style of the
newspaper while giving content to the
reader that helps them understand what's
going on in the story which is why it's
really interesting that grammatically
it's classified as Natural Science which
could be because we don't have a
journalism corpus in here so it could be
that natural science was simply the
closest to journalism or it could be
that in
stokers attempt to mimic journalistic
discourse within a novel he actually
winds up closer to natural science but
lexically it's much more strongly
classified as history because it's doing
the kind of content delivery that
history specializes in and again to
remind you of what those features are
that we're using in natural science a
lot of clauses really long sentences and
a lot of determiners with present tense
verbs which is the mark of both Natural
Sciences as it turns out of certain
kinds of journalism and history again
are those different kinds of history
words particularly a lot of words and a
lot of men okay so we can use this to
just read different novels and say cool
here's a different micro generic bit
that's one thing we can do but but that
that gets old after a little while
although I have to admit there's still a
certain excitement to like running
different novels and being like ooh look
natural science Oh anthropology so that
doesn't get old quite as fast as you
think it would but there are some larger
questions that we have for example one
of the things that we're interested in
doing is reversing the analysis that is
instead of looking at places in novels
where there seems to be different
disciplinary styles we can look in
disciplinary texts and see where they
look like different kinds of writing
other than what they're supposed to be
so for example this is a book called
extinct monsters by hutchinson this is
one of the earliest works on what might
be considered to be paleontology
he writes a lot about dinosaurs as well
as other early fossils most of it is
natural science but there are really
strong anthropological signals and
really strong psychological signals so
the ways in which an early work on
Natural History communicates to its
readers involves a lot of Natural
Science writing so borrowing from things
like physics like early biology as we
might expect but also remix it
with these different kinds of
disciplinary writing a little bit more
anthropology as Hutchinson humanizes the
animals that he studies a little bit
more psychology as he speculates on the
life and the end the extinct lifestyles
of these previous inhabitants of Earth
in the same way
Freud's the interpretation of dreams
classic work of psychology this answers
the prayers of all of the people I know
in psychology who insists that Freud
should not be read in psychology
departments because there's a lot of
psychology but there's also a lot of
what looks like economics and quite a
bit of what looks like philosophy so
it's a way of understanding what Freud
is up to the way in which he's trying to
put together an argument in a
foundational text of a discipline that
doesn't quite exist yet by combining
different kinds of stylistic signatures
into something new so we can use this to
reflect back on what's going on in the
early forms of these disciplines the
other thing we can do and this is sort
of where we are with the project now
this is where I will I will leave you is
that we want to think more broadly about
genres and the ways in which they act
with it with interact sorry with my crew
genre so most of what I've shown you so
far Sherlock Holmes is a detective novel
Bram Stoker obviously is writing a
gothic novel and the other ones that we
looked at were much more literary
science fiction is a really interesting
case I told you most novels are
predominantly classified as novels
except for a couple of instances where
they're not science fiction this is on
the top novel called Looking Backward by
Edward Bellamy about a guy who time
travels a hundred years in the future
and then describes what he sees and at
the bottom a modern utopia by HG Wells
the foundational sort of utopian science
fiction text both of them are mostly not
novel and in fact partake grammatically
a very differ
discourse is a lot of history in the
case of a modern utopia a lot of
anthropology where as Looking Backward
has a lot of things that look like
psychology similarly when we look at
them lexically which should be better at
identifying novels as novels we also
find really strong micro generic signals
so here both Wells and Bellamy seem to
be using a lot of economic discourse and
this actually makes sense if you sit
down and read the novel because they're
really interested in describing to the
reader how the economies of these
utopian societies work in other words
science fiction novels as a genre seem
to be using micro zondra's differently
then other kinds of writing and so one
of the two things were engaged in now is
looking more broadly at these genres and
seeing if there are commonalities
between how different disciplinary
styles get included in them so is
science fiction much more implicated
with things like economics lexically and
history or grammatically and for example
is something like historical fiction
much more interested in historical
writing grammatically and say for
example anthropology lexically so
breaking down the disciplines looking at
these kinds of patterns this is the kind
of thing that we can do with the
computational model but really the
original goal of the project do these
kinds of shifts exist do they exist at
the grammatical level yes and and they
do in ways that we can detect
computationally but which remain I think
invisible for the most part to readers
so thank you
you
[Applause]